DESPITE THE BIG LOSS IS AN
ONGOING SETBACKS IN UKRAINE,
MOSCOW'S MILITARY REACH
CONTINUES TO EXPAND ELSEWHERE,
IN PARTICULAR, BUILDING NEW
BASES IN THE ARCTIC CIRCLE.
DETAILS NOW FROM CNN'S NICK
PATON WALSH.
[SOUND OF ARTILLERY]
UP HERE IN THE ARCTIC, YOU
WOULDN'T GET THE FEELING OF
RUSSIA'S MILITARY HAS CRIPPLED
BY ITS CATASTROPHIC INVASION OF
UKRAINE.
TO MOSCOW, THIS ICE QUICKLY
RECEDING WITH CLIMATE CHANGE IS
VITAL TO ITS DEFENSE AND FUTURE.
THESE NEW SATELLITE IMAGES
OBTAINED BY CNN REVEALED THAT
CHANGES THAT KEY MILITARY
INSTALLATIONS OVER JUST THE
PAST YEAR AND SHOW THAT,
DESPITE THE DAMAGE DONE TO
RUSSIA'S MILITARY FROM THEIR
INVASION OF UKRAINE, THEY ARE
STILL EXPANDING UP NEAR THE
ARCTIC CIRCLE FAST.
TOWARDS THE EAST, THREE DRONES
HAVE BEEN BUILT UP HERE AT
DIXIE BETWEEN THIS OCTOBER AND
LAST.
WORK HERE TO OVER THE LAST YEAR
ON THE RUNWAY IN THE --
FORM OF NEAR THE ARCTIC CIRCLE.
AND ONE OF FIVE NEW RESONANCE
AND RADARS WHICH THEY CLAIM CAN
FIGHT STEALTH JETS EMERGING OUT
OF NOWHERE HERE.
AND THIS NEW BUILDING, AT ONE
RADAR STATION NEAR NORWAY,
EMERGING SINCE JUNE LAST YEAR.
>> IN AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW,
NATO'S CHIEF IS AWARE OF THE
GROWING THREAT.
>> WHAT WE SEE NOW IS A
SIGNIFICANT RUSSIAN MILITARY
BUILDUP IN THE HIGH NORTH.
AS WE SEE, RUSSIA RE-OPENING
ALL OF THE SOVIET BASIS
MILITARY SIDES.
BUT ALSO TESTING NOVEL WEAPONS
IN THE ARCTIC AND THE HIGH
NORTH.
THE ARCTIC IS VITAL TO RUSSIA,
NOT ONLY FOR OIL AND GAS.
BUT ALSO AS PART OF ITS NEW
COLOR DEFENSE.
THE KREMLIN IS ALSO URGENTLY
LAUNCHING NEW ATOMIC
ICEBREAKERS.
TO ENSURE IT RETAINS INFLUENCE
OVER A SHORTER TRADE ROUTE FROM
THE PACIFIC TO EUROPE, OPENED
UP BY CLIMATE CHANGE, REDUCING
THE ARCTIC ICE COVER.
>> BUT THE WAR IN UKRAINE HAS
LED TO A CHANGE ON MAJOR.
SIDES THEY LEAD 75% OF THE
ARTICLE AND FORCED TO UKRAINE,
THE SENIOR WESTERN INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIAL HAS TOLD ME THAT IT'S
NAVY IS ALMOST UNTOUCHED, SEMI
DETACHED FROM THE WAR.
THEY HAD, IT ALSO, AFTER
STRIKES ON THE AIR FEELS DEEP
INSIDE RUSSIA, JUST HAVE BEEN
DISPERSED AROUND ITS TERRITORY,
SOME FOR THE, NORTH BOOSTING
EFFECTIVELY THEY'RE PRESENT IN
THE ARCTIC.
AND NATO IS ALSO SENDING ITS
MESSAGES.
>> WHAT YOU'RE SEEING HERE
LOOKS LIKE A NORMAL DROP OF A
SUPPLY PELLET.
BUT, IT IS AN ON PRESIDENT
SURPRISE OVER NORWAY BY U.S.
SPECIAL FORCES THIS YEAR.
DROPPING OFF A CRUISE MISSILE
ON A PARACHUTE.
HERE, IT IGNITES THE U.S.
MILITARY KEEN TO SHOW THAT IT
CAN FIRE ITS CHARMS FROM A
CARGO PLANE, GREATLY INCREASING
ITS RANGE NEAR RUSSIA.
SHAKEN BY A RECENT SABOTAGE OF
BALTIC SEA PIPELINES, AND NATO
IS NOW FOCUSED ON PROTECTING
NORWAY CENTER G INFRASTRUCTURE,
NOW NORWAY, NOT RUSSIA,
SUPPLIES ABOVE 30% OF THE GAS
EXPORTS TO EUROPE.
>> SINCE THE SABOTAGE IN THE
BALTIC SEA, WE HAVE DOUBLED OUR
PRESENCE WHICH IS WITH THE
SUBMARINES WOULD NOT PATROL
AIRCRAFT IN THE BALTIC AND THE
NORTH OF THE CITY.
>> A CHANGE UNLIKELY TO CALL
MOSCOW OR REDUCE ITS FOOTPRINT
SOMEWHERE SO CLOSE TO HOME.
NICK PATON WALSH, CNN, LONDON.
>> MEANTIME, STATE MEDIA
REPORTS THAT PUTIN WILL LEAVE
THE MEETING, WEDNESDAY
REFERRING THE MILITARY'S
PERFORMANCE THIS, YOUR, ALSO
LAYING OUT ITS TASK FOR NEXT
YEAR.
MORE NOW FROM CNN'S CLARE
SEBASTIAN.
RUSSIA IS CONTINUING TO PUT ON
A SHOW OF INTEGRATION WITH THE
FOUR UKRAINIAN REGIONS IN
ILLEGALLY ANNEXED, PUTIN
AWARDING THE ACTING HEADS OF
THE REGION STATE AWARDS, ON
TUESDAY, PRAISING THEIR
CONTRIBUTION TO THE MOTHERLAND.
EVEN AS RUSSIA'S EFFORTS TO
MAINTAIN CONTROL OF THOSE
TERRITORY FLANDERS.
AND, AS IF TO HAVE AT THE,
POINT UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY HELD HIS OWN AWARDS
CEREMONY ON TUESDAY.
FOR SOLDIERS, ACTUALLY IN ONE
OF THOSE ANNEXED REGIONS, IN
DONETSK.
DYLAN SKI PAID A SURPRISE VISIT
TO THE TOWN OF BAKHMUT AN AREA
CURLIER --
CURRENTLY SEEING THE MOST
INTENSE FIGHTING IN THE WAR.
PRESIDENT PUTIN IS CLEARLY
FACING MOUNTING PRESSURE, A DAY
EARLIER, HE ACTUALLY ADMITTED
THAT THE SITUATION IN THOSE
REGIONS WAS QUITE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT.
, INCREASINGLY ATTACKS ON
RUSSIAN SOIL, HE IS TIGHTENING
CONTROL AT HOME DURING RUSSIA
SECURITY SERVICES TO STEP UP
SURVEILLANCE AND WHAT HE CALLED
TRAITORS, SPIES AND SABOTEURS.
AND TO STEP OF CONTROL, THE
COUNTRY'S BORDERS AND STRATEGIC
FACILITY.
IT HEADS TO THE END OF THE YEAR
WITH MINIMAL GAINS, DESPITE A
PARTIAL MOBILIZATION, RUSSIA'S
NEXT MOVE IN THE CONFLICT IS
THE SUBJECT OF MUCH SPECULATION
ON WEDNESDAY HE SAID TO MEET
WITH THE BOARD OF DEFENSE
MINISTRY AND THAT WILL BE
CLOSELY WATCHED.
CLARE SEBASTIAN, CNN, LONDON.